depuis le début du confinement certaines
entreprises ont dû se mettre à l'arrêt
et sont au chômage technique
une mésaventure qui n'est pas arrivé at
hinder et à de nombreux sites et
applications de rencontres dont le
trafic depuis le début du confinement
explose littéralement si cela peut
paraître paradoxal dans cette période où
il est justement impossible de se
rencontrer il faut croire que les gens
ont besoin de communiquer selon les
chiffres annoncés par l'application
américaine thunder le 29 mars dernier se
sont même plus de 3 milliards de ce web
qui ont été réalisés sur l'application
comprenait 3 milliards d'actions pour
sélectionner ou non les profils de ceux
à qui on veut parler mais en plus d'être
actif sur ses applications les
utilisateurs y restent plus longtemps en
moyenne les conversations dur 23% de
plus qu'avant globalement la libido des
confiné et à bloc on peut l'observer
grâce à un phénomène la montée en
puissance de l'utilisation sur les
réseaux sociaux des émaux j pêche et
aubergines qui évoque on le sait le sexe
féminin et masculin une augmentation de
46% en un mois bref autant de signaux
qui montrent qu'après le déconfinement
ça va être la fête du slip
ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais
après le dépouillement
ça risque d'être un petit peu chaud les
chéris alors l'on sait expliquer aux
téléspectateurs vous êtes célibataire
qu'est ce qui s'est passé sans nous dire
le nom etc mais vous pouvez nous dire ce
qui s'est passé exactement de série
apparemment trouvé la boue alors qu'est
ce qui s'est passé moi tu vas pas
peut-être pas trouvé l'amour on n'irait
pas jusque là mais disons que grâce à
vos appels répétés comme de lady
certaines personnes effectivement mieux
approcher par téléphone ou par message
comment comment ils ont eu lente et
quand ils ont les votre téléphone ben je
réussis à l'abord met d'ailleurs c'est
pas des gens que vous connaissez aussi
peut-être que nous ont demandé le numéro
voyez enfin je dirais pas plus loin sur
le sujet néanmoins il se trouvait là je
me dis qu'après le confinement pourquoi
pas est ce que c'est un homme politique
oui mais pas du tout non pas du tout
benjamin griveaux c'est pas mal jamais
grippaux
quelle lourde peur qu'il est concentré
oui prenez réveil merci que vous êtes un
petit peu le cupidon de cette émission
et que donc c'est peut-être par notre
intermédiaire sans vincent
éventuellement le faire de façon ouais
ouais c'est vrai vous avez permis
éventuellement une petite histoire pour
olemps je suis pas le pilon moi je suis
plutôt le cul sans pilote voilà minimes
et gilles verdez oui mais il faut
vraiment enquêter parce que là elle a
quand même dit que c'est sans doute
passé par vous donc cyril pour il y
avait une mémoire infaillible
est-ce que vous avez oui ou non
communiqué son numéro à quelqu'un parce
que mon avis une piste allait là à oui
oui oui oui j'en parlerai bien sûr au
journal de 20 heures oui alors les
chéris juste pour savoir est-ce que vous
avez déjà été sur un site de rencontres
est-ce que vous avez déjà voilà qu'elle
s'était pas votre pseudo vous jean
michel fotso thomas 75 non photo marcel
castet votre pseudo sur les sites de
rencontres c'est exactement bay paris
sont thomas et les filles savaient que
c'était fou après comment allez-vous
mettre nu mais même pas falloir que j'y
suis encore sous ce pseudo allez
messieurs 1
d'accord pas très bien très bien vous
avez fait des rencontres grâce à ça et
jean-michel énorme énormément et dans le
genre non mais non mais c'est vrai que
toute façon tout est un site de
rencontre maintenant les gens qui sont
sur le web ça pète c'est tout un cidre
condamnation vous avez les à l'adresse
de quelqu'un vous voyez le profil de
quelqu'un vous recevez un message c'est
assez quelque part même si les filles se
rendent pas toujours compte aussi une
façon de prendre contact d'approcher un
peu et des convois affronter les petits
messages un peu ambigu sur thomas
inconsciemment et si on voit que ça
répond à plaider des points de
suspension lycée le web impacté quoi de
si tu es très je te trouve très sympa
trois suspensions évidemment ça veut
dire que t'es bonne et madame on est des
gens michel toujours l'élégance
l'élégance à la française
jean-michel toujours la classe absolue
vraiment ils sont sur un site de
rencontres non non non je m'ai fait une
fois il ya longtemps mais avec la
politique c'est pas possible c'est sûr
rené malleville est ce que tu es sur un
site de rencontres toi t'es sur kindle
je ne sais même pas où et comment y
aller en colère tu sais comment les
chefs mais comme ça mais j'ai jamais
regardé aucune de cul je sais pas ce que
c'est de regarder nord bat as raison je
n'ai jamais et je n'ai jamais eu besoin
de ses fantasmes n'ont pas lieu d'être a
bien fait bah oui voilà et et normes
toit de satyam est vraiment atteinte a
connu 4 6 commun de meuf dans ta vie
rené nan mais je recevrai la côté de toi
il est fort le marsaillais alors ils
savaient qu'en attendant de se voir il
ya plein de gens qui envoient des danses
sexy
vous savez les petites dents si les
petites vidéos sexy voilà
et ils s'utilisent aussi les appels en
visio pour faire des lieux danse et fait
bien attention de ne pas appeler la
mauvaise personnes ont regardé ce qui
est arrivé à une jeune fille
alors voilà et oui elle a appelé son
père la preuve elle apprécie verna mais
est ce que vous vous rendez compte de la
réaction du pape a nommé sonné il va
être content et fier ya ma fille qui
m'appelle oh lalala lalala 66,1 la
histadrout vallespir tout le paquet pour
elle tu vas tati comme ça dans cette
situation là on se sait pire que pour
elle qui a fait le mauvais niveau
vraiment et elle est là elle accuse elle
a là qu'une envie c'est qu'on soit plus
jamais des confidents elle dit quand je
vais voir mon père et balnéaire est tous
là et ils vont penser qu'à ça ferait les
frais
oui oui jean michel louis est ce qui est
surtout un supporter à leurs basques
bourthes labour il aujourd'hui c'est que
tous les appareils sont interconnectées
quand vous en voyez quelque chose sur
votre téléphone
ça peut se retrouver sur l'ipad va
regarder enfin castaldi par exemple bah
oui parce que quand je l'aide quand je
suis parti vivre en amérique j'avais
oublié que mon ipad à paris était
connecté à mon téléphone là bas donc
quand même vous faites des textos ça
arrive aussi sur l'ipad dont j'ai un
petit coup de téléphone de ma de ma
femme de l'époque mais ça se passe bien
la soirée je dis oui très bien j'étais
tout seul
même mauvaise soirée pour moi c'était
dans mon cas mais je le comprends
oui j'ai leur club c'est tellement
populaire qu'il ya 118 plateforme de
rencontres utilisé par près de 3
millions de français sinon rien comme
suit 1 118 alex henry